[Musik]
so ihr lieben heute werden wir für euch
unser erstes verrückt klingen das
gericht kochen wenn ihr ideen fragen
oder anregungen haben lasst es uns
wissen
das ganze rezept und die zutaten dazu
haben wir euch in die beschreibung
geschrieben und wie das alles zubereitet
wird zeigen wir euch in dem video
dieses mal gibt es himmel und erde das
ist ein gericht aus der westfälischen
regionen im westen deutschlands
dazu werden zuerst die kartoffeln
geschält gewaschen und ein bisschen
klein geschnitten
übrigens so ein traditionell kann das
gericht gar nicht sein denn die
kartoffel ist er mittlerweile typisch
deutsch aber ihr ursprung liegt gar
nicht in deutschland ist das so
ursprünglich kommt die kartoffel aus
südamerika aber mittlerweile gibt es sie
natürlich in jedem gewächshaus und in
jedem supermarkt gut für alle die himmel
und erde machen wollen hallo
entschuldigung
jetzt kann ich das alles nochmal
erzählen das interessiert doch sowieso
niemand doch das ist total spannend
sicher entschuldigung ich wollte nicht
stören ja zu spät was was wollen sie
hier
ich weiß sie mögen mich nicht weil ich
ihn belogen habe
aber lassen sie es mich wieder gut
machen
ich liebe ihn von ganzem herzen
dann sagen sie ihr dass sie hört mir
nicht zu dass ich die ganze zeit laufen
das ist pech vielleicht proteinen zu
hören
ich flehe sie an helfen sie mir
[Musik]